Çeviri: Ceren Üstündağ
Gözden geçirme: Figen Ergürbüz
30 yaşın üzerinde olanlar
şöyle bir el kaldırabilirler mi?
30 yaşın altında olanlar?
Tam arada olanlar?
Tamam.
Arada olanlar ve 30 yaşın altında olanlara
şimdiden söyleyeyim:
Geçmiş olsun.
Ben 30 yaşıma kadar sevdiğim insanlar
ve onları mutlu etmek için yaşadım.
Onların mutluluğu, onların hoşnutluğu
benim için çok kıymetliydi.
Bunun için dediler ki:
İyi okullara gitmen lazım.
Sınavlara girip derece yaptık.
Ondan sonra, yurt dışına gitmek için
burs imkanı oldu.
"Yok, kız kısmı memleketinde okur."
dediler.
Dizimizi kırdık.
Sonra dediler ki:
Geleceksin aile işinde çalışacaksın.
Kendimi kaybedercesine
o aile işinde çalıştım.
Sonra ne oldu?
Onları mutlu edebildim mi dersiniz?
Edemedim.
Kendim mutlu oldum mu?
Hiç olmadım ve içimden gelen o ses
yavaş yavaş sönmeye başlamıştı.
Bence bana küsmüştü.
Artık "Nush ile uslanmayanı etmeli tekdir,
tekdir ile uslanmayanın hakkı kötektir."
cinsinde zona oldum.
Ondan sonra tansiyonum çıktı
ki şuandaki kilomun
neredeyse yarısı kadardım.
Yani öyle kilo ile de alakalı değil.
Sonra tekrar zona oldum.
Sonra çok acayip bir şey başıma geldi.
Aslında bu birçok psikologun
perspektifinde de olan,
otuz yaşındaki ikinci ergenliği
bir nevi temsil ediyor.
Otuz yaşına kadar
kendimizi ispat etmek için,
bu dünyada var etmek için,
sevdiklerime beğendirmek için
epey bir çaba sarf ediyoruz.
Fakat otuz yaşında aynı mekikler gibi,
bilmem bilir misiniz,
mekikler uzaya çıkarken
çok ciddi bir güç harcar
ve aslında yanlardaki
kocaman tankları bitirir
ve ondan sonra onları atar.
İşte otuzda
o başkasını mutlu etme kompartımanları
büyük ölçüde düşüyor.
Bitiyor mu?
Tabii ki bitmiyor.
Bu otuz artı bir ya da eksi bir tabii ki
fark oluyor aynı ergenlikteki gibi.
Çok mutsuz bir dönemde,
hatta hiç unutmayacağım bir şeydir,
içimde başkasına verebilecek mercimek
kadar bir şey kalmadığı hissim çok netti.
Bu ağır, bu depresif halden
çıkmaya çalışırken,
Candan Erçetin'in bir şarkısı var:
Yapabilseydin eğer, yola çıksaydın eğer,
neler yapardın neler.
Bunu dinlediğim bir anda,
odamda pijamalarımla iken
masanın üzerinde çok sevdiğim bir arkadaşımın
bana Amerika'dan getirdiği taş vardı.
Şöyle minik bir taş, onu da getirdim.
Burada "You must be the change
you wish to see in the world."
Gandhi'nin lafı yazıyor.
Dünyada görmek istediğin
değişiklik kendin ol.
Bu laflar bir anda böyle içimde bir
"evreka anı" yaşattı.
Evet, biraz bununla ilgili.
O "İçimde bir mercimek tanesi kadar
bir şey yok." dediğim zamanda
beni tek mutlu eden şey;
yaptığım yemeklerdi.
Ben disleksiyim,
o yüzden tarif takip edemem.
Bana verin bir reçeteyi "Bunu yap."
derseniz ortalığı dağıtırım.
Böyle olduğum için hep malzemeleri alır,
kendimce yemekler icat ederdim o zaman
ve gelen giden arkadaşlarım
bundan çok mutlu olurlardı.
Demin İzzet'in de söylediği gibi,
işte bu yemekleri yaparken
karşıdaki insanın mutluluğu başka türlü,
onun yüz ifadesini görmek de
ayrıca bir tatmin yaratırdı.
O anda beni tek mutlu eden yemek
benim kurtarıcım oldu.
Bir kitap yazmaya karar verdikten sonra
tabii ki sıkıntılarla da beraber,
mucizevi bir yolculuk başladı.
Bu yolculuğu şuanda
çok uzun bir şekilde anlatmayacağım
ama size oradaki
öğrendiğim şeyi söyleyebilirim:
İçindeki sesi dinle, hayal et ve iste.
Hayalin muhakkak gerçekleşecektir.
Senin istediğin zamanda ve şekilde mi?
Hayır.
Evrenin istediği zamanda
ama senin hayal ettiğinden
daha güzel bir şekilde.
Bu nasıl derseniz işte kitabı yazdım,
çok güzel, kendimce bayılıyorum.
Herkes böyle götürdüğüm an
"Biz sizi bekliyorduk, ne kadar güzel."
diyecek derken hiç öyle olmadı.
Ondan sonra baktılar.
"Ah canım benim,
bu kitap için çok uğraşmışsın.
ama bunu kimse okumaz.
Sen en iyisi bu bilgileri
post-it haline getir de başına koy."
diyen oldu.
Ondan sonra "Bu kitapta yeni bir şey yok."
diyen vesaire vesaire...
Ama bir şekilde inanıyordum.
O kitap benim ilk defa...
Yani benim için o sırada
satar mı satmaz mı önemli değildi,
sadece o içimdekini ve sadece ama sadece
kendim için çıkarmam önemliydi.
Satmazsa da en kötü,
anneannemin bir kitabı var der torunum,
diye düşünüyordum.
Ama bir yayın evi,
altıncı ya da yedinciydi sanırım,
altı aylık bir sürecin sonunda
15 dakika içerisinde kabul etti.
Kitap çıktı.
Üçüncü haftasında tamamen satıldı.
O yıl içerisinde üç tane kopya yaptı.
Financial Times'a kadar yazdı.
Hürriyet, daha üçüncü hafta bile dolmadan,
gazetede yazarlık teklif etti.
Hatta o teklifte
benimle röportaj yapmışlardı.
Beni çok şey yapmadılar,
herhalde forslu birinin röportajını
koyacaklar,
özür dilemek için çağırdılar zannettim.
"Böyle böyle, yazar mısınız?"
dediklerinde koltuktan filan düştüm.
Kendi zamanlamasında ama
düşlediğinden daha güzel olacak hayalleri
gerçekten evren böyle verebiliyor.
Çok küçücük bir anekdot
daha paylaşmak istiyorum.
O da televizyon programı.
İlk televizyon programına başlayacağız,
işte zaten diyorum ki;
yurt dışında çok güzel
televizyon programları var.
Bizim yemeklerimizle bu programlar
ne kadar acayip olabilir,
diye böyle hayal ediyorum.
Tabii zorlu tarafları da olmadı mı?
İşte anlaştık, gittik.
Kanalın en yetkili kişisi
artı on sekiz kişi daha oturuyoruz.
Ben böyle çok havalıyım,
en güzel kıyafetlerimi giyinmişim.
Dediler ki:
Biz senin yanına manken vermek istiyoruz.
Önce şaka zannettim,
böyle espriye alıyorum.
Hiç öyle bir şey yok.
Dedim ki:
Tamam, kadıncağız ile bir şeyim yok
ama hani kadının görev tanımında
"yemek yememek" var.
Biz burada iştahla ilgili,
samimiyetle ilgili bir program yapacağız.
Emin misiniz?
Nuh diyor peygamber demiyorlar.
Ondan sonra, ben biraz daha ısrar edince
başındaki adam dedi ki:
Öyle herkes kendisini
Jamie Oliver zannetmesin,
Jamie Oliver gibi biri çıksaydı
zaten bugüne kadar çıkardı.
Bu laf tabii atalarımızdan öğrendiğimiz
Hilal Taktiğini uygulamak için
o asil kanın damarlarımızda var olduğunun
kanıtı olarak şöyle bir geri çekildim
ve
"Bakın, bugüne kadar bizim memleketimizde
böyle bir insan çıkmamış olabilir
ama çıkmamasının sebebi;
böyle bir hatta birkaç tane insanın
var olup olmaması değil
bu koltuklarda oturan insanlar.
Bu toplantı burada bitmiştir,
çok teşekkürler."
deyip kalkıp gittim
ama zangır zangır da titriyorum.
Tam hayalimi kısaca anlatmak istiyorum.
Bir Fransız'ın alelade bir günde
kız arkadaşına lahmacun yapması.
Bu garip geliyor mu bilmiyorum.
Garip gelmesin.
Şöyle düşünün:
On altı yaşında yakışıklı bir oğlan,
kız arkadaşını eve çağırıyor.
Ne yapar?
İşte, hayatım sana pestolu makarna yaptım.
Olmayacak bir şey gibi geliyor mu bu?
O zaman bizim lahmacun da öyle
çünkü bizim mutfak kültürümüz
bir İtalyan mutfak kültürü kadar güzel
ve yayılabilecek bir durumda aslında
veya pizza olarak düşündüğünüzde,
neden olmasın?
Bunun için kafamda yazdığım
temel listeler vardı.
İnsanların mutfakta
güzel vakit geçirmeleri,
iyi kitapların, iyi programların olması...
En iyi on restoranda, bundan on yıl evvel,
Türk mutfağı ile ilgili,
Anadolu mutfağıyla ilgili hiç yemek yoktu.
Şimdi artık var.
Mezeler, hep aynı otuz çeşit meze vardı,
artık farklı şeyler için yarışıyorlar.
İyisi var kötüsü var elbet ama her şey
bir şekilde akarak yolunu bulacaktır.
Yemekle haşır neşir bir gençlik denilince
bundan yine on yıl evvel,
Boluluları hariç tutarak,
kızı, oğlu aşçı olmak istediğinde
ağlayan anneler
bugün futbolcu anneleri gibi gururlular.
Üniversitede çok güzel programlar oluyor
ama daha da önemlisi;
bizim kendimizi eleştirerek değil,
kendimiz ve kültürümüz
ile gurur duyduğumuz bir hale doğru...
Bunu da yemek üzerinden
çünkü öyle bir bereket var ki
bu topraklarda...
Bunu hissettirmek için de
aslında yemek çok güzel bir yol.
Ben bunu nasıl yapmaya çalışıyorum?
Sarma, dolma böyle de olabilir.
Yıllardır böyle yapıldı.
İşte, serçe parmak gibi
ama aslında dolma neden böyle olmasın?
Hatta bu dolmayı niye yaptın derseniz;
bu dolma kendimi bir hayaller ülkesinde
gibi hissetmeye başladığımda,
o zamanlarda, hani bari külkedisi
isem kabağa sonra dönmeyeyim diye
kabağı bari pişireyim de
ondan sonra kötü yola düşmeyelim diye...
Bu, o zaman yaptığım
bir yılbaşındaki kabak idi.
Su muhallebisi artık ne yazık ki
bu kültür değişime adapte olamadığı için
bir şekilde belirli değişikliklere
uğraması gerekiyordu.
Mesela bu su muhallebisinin
reşikaca versiyonu.
İşte, çok güzel bir suyu var altında,
muhallebisi portakal çiçeği sulu,
böyle soğuk bir şerbet ile.
Eğer künefe hep künefe olarak kalırsa,
Canan hoca da sağ olsun,
kadayıf ustaları da işsiz kalacak diye
ben de kendime misyon edindim,
onu mantıya çevirdim.
Çok lezzetli oluyor,15 dakikada da
yapabiliyorsunuz bu mantıyı.
Çorba da noodle gibi
veya bir börek olarak veya Almanlara,
Avusturyalılara kapak olsun diye
schnitzel hali de çok iyi oluyor.
Uzak doğululara ama kapak olmasın dimi?
Onların çıtır muzundan esinlenerek
sadece balla ve 3 dakikada,
ben bunu kaynana geldiğinde
yapılacak tatlı diye de söylüyorum.
Ben demin güllaçla çalışırken de
güllacı illa beyaz
ve sadece ramazanda mı yemek zorundayız?
Hayır, çikolatalı baya yıkılıyor.
Bu pizza versiyonu.
Pizza versiyonu da müthiştir
veya böyle çok lezzetli bir börek,
lazanya gibi de olarak.
Yufka inanılmaz bir zanaat;
4 yılda, yetenekliyseniz öğrenebilirsiniz.
Sadece börek değil,
nefis bir Türk sushisi de olabilir
veya bir böyle pestili alın,
içerisine dondurmayı koyun,
etrafına yufkayı sarın,
derin dondurucuya atın.
Misafir geldi,
onların güzelce dışı çıtır çıtır oldu
ve ondan sonra yediniz.
Mis gibi oluyor
ve içinde taş gibi donan o pestil
hafif erimiş oluyor.
Çok acayip bir şey oluyor.
Yemek yediğinizi düşünerek koymuştum.
Milli içeceğimiz olan ayranın
sadece yine beyaz
veya salatalıklı
veya naneli hali değil;
acı turşu sulu, arapsaçlı
ve özellikle şimdi erik zamanı geliyor,
yeşil eriğin suyunu sıkıp karıştırıp
bakın ne acayip oluyor.
Benim için deneyin diyorum ve geçiyorum.
Bunlar hayal edebildiğimiz zaman
gerçekleşebilen şeyler
fakat son zamanlarda,
son 1 buçuk yıldır, bir şey fark ettim ki;
ben hayal kuramamaya başladım
ve neden diye baktığımda
memleketin hali, ekonomik kriz,
dünyanın sevimsizleşmesi...
Hem bir taraftan maddi manevi
böyle bu zorlukların içerisinde
bal kabağında pilavdan bahsetmek
Müslüman mahallesinde salyangoz satmak
gibi oluyor.
Türk mutfağını kurtarmaya çalışmak da
bambaşka bir şey.
Dönem çok acayip;
bir sürü seçenek var.
"Onu mu yapsak bunu mu yapsak?"
derken yine arada kalabiliyor insan.
Dolayısıyla...
Bu seçenek fazlalığı da bir diğer şey.
Sizde de var dimi bu his?
Olanlar?
Evet, işte.
Çaresini buldum merak etmeyin.
Neden neden derken
Instagram'a bir tane post koydum.
Post şu:
Bunun onuncu dakikasında
cep telefonuma annemden gelen mesaj:
Refika, bu beyaz tişörtleri giyinmekten
ne zaman vazgeçeceksin?
Karnımı iki kompartımanlı gösteren
bu beyaz tişörtler
benim 2. evraka anımı yaşamama sebep oldu.
Ben fark ettim ki;
Hep bir hafta sonra o haftaya göre
daha zayıf olacağıma inanıyorum.
ve bunun için kendimce dikkat ediyorum
ama şurada göstereyim size:
Bu benim son 15 yıldaki kilo eğrim.
Burada düşen bir yer var,
ikinci daha dramatik olan.
Oradaki düşüş aslında
yemek kitabımı çıkardıktan sonra
o mucizelerin yaşandığı
bir buçuk iki yıllık süre
ama gördüğünüz gibi
gayet istikrarla yukarı çıkmışım.
"Neden böyle? Neden böyle?"
deyince aslında şunu fark ettim:
Bu evreka anı bir kızın, 24 yaşındaki
bir Youtuber'ın programını izlerken
orada "Elinde olabileceğinin en iyisi ol."
gibi bir laf etti.
Ama hani laf arasında.
"Bugün olabileceğinin en iyisi ol."
Bu böyle bir yankılanmaya başladı.
Şimdi şöyle bir hadise var:
Biz nasıl bir durumdayız?
Her gün kendimize yapmamız gerekenlerin
listelerini yapıyoruz
Ve bu listelerin üzerinden geçerek
üstlerini çizmeye çalışıyoruz.
Bu listeler gittikçe büyüyor
ve bu listeleri
yapabilmek için ne yapıyoruz?
Bardağın boş tarafı
yani eksiklerimiz neler
onlara bakmaya çalışıyoruz.
Eksikler belli, bir sürü şey var
Olmak istediğimiz yer ne
bütün öğretilerde?
Sen zaten doğduğun için çok kıymetlisin,
çok değerlisin.
Ne bir şey yapmak zorundasın...
Zaten bu dünyanın bütün nimetlerini
hak ediyorsun ama mal bu.
Bizim eğitimimiz,
yüzde doksanımız diye tahmin ediyorum,
bu taraftayız.
Buraya gelmek için mesafe çok büyük.
Dolayısıyla bu aslında bu ideale
gelebilmek için atılabilecek bir adım.
Sabah uyandığınızda, dolabınızı açtınız,
çok güzel hissetmiyor olabilirsiniz.
Haftaya daha güzel olurum da
daha güzel giyinirim değil
"Mal bu. Bununla en güzel ne yapabilirim?"
dediğiniz zaman dolabınızda
yeni kıyafetler belirmeye başlıyor.
Yani aslında dolu tarafına,
var olana bakmak.
Hep eksiklerimiz üzerinden giden,
hesaplanan bütün bu tüketim dünyası,
var olana baktığınızda
bambaşka bir yere dönüyor.
Bu sadece, tabii ki,
dolapta veya giyinirken değil;
saçınızda, başınızda, fiziksel değil.
İşinizde, sevdiklerinizle geçirdiğiniz
vaktin kalitesi de aynı zamanda değişiyor.
O gün öyle yaşadığınız zaman
aslında çok büyük bir huzur doğuyor.
Kanıtı da; bakın buna aydığımdan beri
kilo eğrim, son bölümü.
Aslında daha bile dramatik de
o süreyi matematiksel olarak ayarlamayı
beceremedim.
Dolayısıyla hayal kurabildiğimiz zaman
ona çok güzel sarılacağız
ve onun için çok çalıştıktan sonra
bileceğiz ki o hayal gerçekleşecek.
Kendi istediğimiz zamanda ve şekilde değil
ama hayal ettiğimizden
çok daha güzel bir şekilde olacak
ama evrenin istediği zamanda.
Edemediğimiz zamanda da
elimizdekinin en iyisini yapabileceğiz.
Gördüğünüz gibi
artık yeni tişörtüm de var.
Bu tişörtlerin var olduğunu
15 yıl sonra öğrendiğim iyi oldu.
Yapışmadan,
kompartıman göstermeden olabiliyor.
Teşekkür ederim.
(Alkış)